écoutez déclaration va pas rater le
début de mi temps qu'on l'attend non
monsieur je vous cite la déclaration de
françois fillon en direct sur les
chaînes parlementaires c'est tout de
suite le 15 marche par les juges
d'instruction afin d'être mis en examen
il est sans exemple dans une affaire de
cette importance qu une convocation aux
fins de mise en examen soit lancé
quelques jours à peine après la
désignation des juges sans qu'ils aient
pris connaissance du dossier ni procéder
à des investigations supplémentaires sur
la simple base d'un rapport de police
manifestement à charge c'est à dire pour
condamner les seuls cas que l'on connaît
ce sont ceux où les personnes
reconnaissait les fêtes et demandé leur
mise en examen pour avoir accès au
dossier
mais je ne reconnais pas les fêtes je
n'ai pas détourné d'argent public
j'ai confié comme près d'un tiers des
parlementaires des travaux à mes proches
parce que je savais pouvoir compter sur
leur confiance et sur leurs compétences
ils m'ont effectivement assisté et je le
démontrerai cette convocation s'inscrit
dans la ligne d'une enquête menée depuis
le début exclusivement à charge depuis
l'origine et contrairement à ce qui a
été dit je n'ai pas été traité comme un
justiciable comme les autres
l' enquête préliminaire a été ouverte en
quelques heures
les procès verbaux contrairement à la
loi ont été immédiatement communiquée à
la presse sans qu'à aucun moment le
garde des sceaux ne s'en émeuve l'état
de droit a été systématiquement violées
la presse s'est fait l'écho des
convictions des enquêteurs et d'elles
seules les arguments de fait que j'ai
présentées n'ont pas été entendus ni
relayé les arguments de droit partagé
par des grands professeurs de droit par
un ancien secrétaire général du conseil
constitutionnel ont été écartée d'un
revers de la main la présomption
d'innocence a complètement est
entièrement
disparu que je ne sois pas un
justiciable comme les autres on le voit
au simple choix de cette date du 15 mars
deux jours avant la clôture des
parrainages entièrement calculé pour
m'empêcher d'être candidat à la
présidentielle et au delà pour empêcher
la droite et le centre de disposer d'un
candidat
les avocats ont demandé que la chambre
de l'instruction de la cour d'appel
statue
immédiatement sur les irrégularités
nombreuses et graves de la procédure
cela leur a été refusé nombre de mes
amis politiques et de ceux qui m'ont
soutenu à la primaire et ses quatre
millions d'électeurs parle d'un
assassinat politique
c'est un assassinat en effet mais par ce
déchaînement disproportionnée sans
précédent connu par le choix de ce
calendrier
ça n'est pas moi seulement qu'on
assassine
c'est l'élection présidentielle c'est le
vote des électeurs de la droite et du
centre qui est fauché
c'est la voie des millions de français
qui désirent une vraie alternance qui
est muselée c'est le projet du
redressement national que je porte qui
est expulsé du débat c'est la liberté du
suffrage
et c'est la démocratie politique elle
même qui sont violemment percutés je
veux qu'il ne subsiste aucun doute à cet
égard je me rendrai à la convocation des
juges
je suis respectueux de nos institutions
je ne désespère pas de la justice même
si ce que nous venons d'en voir n'est
pas de nature à nous rassurer
je leur dirai ma vérité qui est la
vérité mais aujourd'hui c'est à vous mes
chers compatriotes que je m'adresse au
delà de la procédure judiciaire
c'est au peuple français et à lui seul
que j'en appelle désormais à ceux qui me
suivent comme à ceux qui me combattent
c'est au peuple français que je m'en
remets
parce que seul le suffrage universel et
non pas une procédure menée à charge
peut décider qui sera le prochain
président de la république je ne céderai
pas je ne me rendrais pas je ne me
retirerai pas j'irai jusqu'au bout parce
qu'au delà de ma personne c'est la
démocratie qui est défiée je vous
demande de me suivre
c'est pas de moi qu'il s'agit de mes
droits ou de la présomption d'innocence
c'est de vous dont la volonté souveraine
ne peut pas être annulé anil est
détruite
je serai au rendez vous que la
démocratie est elle seule nous donne
pour choisir notre avenir collectif
j'y serai avec une détermination
redoublé
je ne permettrai pas que le seul choix
qui nous soit collectivement données
soit celui de la folle aventure
d'extrême droite ou de la continuation
du hollandisme je n'accepte pas que tout
s'organise pour nous amener un pas après
l'autre dans la voie du renoncement du
déclin de l'oubli de ce qui fait notre
grandeur nationale
la france est plus grande que nous la
france est plus grande que mes erreurs
elle est plus grande que les partis pris
d'une large partie de la presse
elle est plus grande que les
emballements de l'opinion elle même et
c'est parce que je suis totalement
décidés à servir cette france là que je
m'opposerai de toutes mes forces à ce
que le hasard ou le calcul décide de son
sort et de l'avenir des français au
moment d'une consultation décisive je
vous le dis avec gravité
ne vous laissez pas abuser ne laissez
personne vous priver de votre choix
parce que votre voix seule doit décider
de notre avenir commun
et parce que ma volonté de servir est
plus grande que les accusations qui sont
portées contre moi je vous demande de
résister
je le fais ma famille le fait malgré
tout les tourments ma famille politique
le fera et au delà d'elle tous ceux qui
croient qu'à la fin seul le peuple peut
décider
oui je serai candidat à la présidence de
la république et nous tirons de ces
épreuves avec tout ce qu'elle comporte
de justes et d'injuste le surcroît de
force qu'il nous faut pour l'emporter et
pour redresser notre pays
je vous remercie voilà pourquoi